-Hey, buddy.
Nice to see you.
Thank you for coming back
on the show.
-Thank you for having me back.
It's like almost what?
A year since last time I think?
-That's the trophy
right behind you?
-Yeah, there it is,
that's the bad boy.
-Congrats, bud. This is
the second year in a row
that your team won the
Overwatch League Grand Finals.
Could you first quickly explain
what Overwatch is for anyone
who doesn't know?
-Yeah, yeah.
Basically Overwatch,
it's 6 versus 6.
a team-based action game by
Blizzard Entertainment.
The goal -- you've got different
maps,
you got different objectives on
these different maps,
you play with
a wide range of heroes,
they all have different
abilities,
and you work together and you
complete the objectives.
-Well, this year, the win --
obviously this year's
a little different.
Last time we talked you were in
the Wells Fargo Center
in front of 12,000 people.
This is a photo right after
you won. This is last year.
Look at that.
-Yeah.
-And now this is a photo of what
winning looks like in 2020.
-[ Laughs ]
-Still exciting but a different
scene, huh?
-Right, yeah, I mean, last year
it was super exciting because,
you know, I'm from Philadelphia,
Wells Fargo Center,
I've been there many times.
I saw Flyers games there
a ton as a kid.
This year, still feels pretty
good, but it's a lot different.
There's no crowds, there's no
excitement in the big arenas,
the sold-out arenas.
It was actually kind of funny
'cause I remember
a lot of people were curious
'cause, like, the rooms
that we played in were so small
that, like, I couldn't be
with the rest of my team
when they were playing,
but, you know,
it still feels good --
feels good to win again.
-That's great, bud.
Gamers all have nicknames,
and you go by the nickname
"Super."
-Yes.
-Wow. Okay, how did that --
Where did that come about?
'Cause you're that good?
-Well, actually, it was 'cause
when I was a lot younger,
my brother --
I watched him play a game.
It was called Runescape,
way back in the day.
I was, like, a little kid.
And I wanted to play but I
was -- what? -- four years old?
I didn't know how to set up an
account or anything like that,
so I asked him to help me, and
the name that he came up with --
I don't know
how he got this name.
It was Super71000.
And that's what I stuck with
for a while.
But then at some point I just
decided the numbers look stupid,
so I cut off the numbers and
then I just was stuck with super
and I just -- I just kept it.
-Is there a formula
to come up --
How could I come up with
my gamer name?
-You find inspiration for
literally anything.
-Okay, I could do...
This is the Little Empire State.
I could be "Empire." Empire.
-There you go.
-Or this is
the Statue of Liberty,
but it's an old thermometer.
Maybe "Old Thermometer."
That's my gamer name.
-Hey, listen, if you're feeling
it, that's all you.
-Jimmy "Old Thermometer" Fallon.
"And a come-from-behind win
from 'Old Thermometer!'"
Now that you have two
championships under your belt,
the big question people
want to know.
Are you planning on going for
the three-peat?
-Yeah, I mean, before playoffs,
actually, our general manager,
he made us watch "The Last
Dance" documentary as a team.
So, you know, Chicago Bulls,
Michael Jordan,
that whole ordeal.
And, you know, for me, it added,
like, motivation to just
kind of, like, go out there
and do it again
because I feel like e-sports
and, like, professional gaming
is still so young that I have
a unique position to be
one of the first dynasties
in e-sports.
I think that's really exciting
and really fun to kind of, like,
cement yourself in that domain.
But, you know, I don't want to
think too far in the future
because then you
overthink things
and you get all anxious
and nervous.
I just take it,
you know, day by day.
We'll see where the wind goes.
-I think you're already
in the history books, buddy.
Congrats.
-Thank you.
-Matthew "Super" Delisi,
everyone.
Congratulations again, pal.